between world number one magnus carlsen
and
world number three dingley ran after the
first day of semifinals we
definitely thought these two would play
that big final
uh those bishops that i love so much uh
right now the white bishops don't look
fantastic but especially white's light
squared bishop it has no rival
if he feels it's necessary okay magnus
just dropping back his bishop potential
with the bishop purse i'm always a
little bit wary
but for the time being i do think that
black is okay in the position and
it's going to be about who can
outmaneuver the opponent who can use the
strength in their position
could be improved when it comes to
temperature and
a nice move from magnus uh moving his
rook so it stares down the black queen
and ding i just like this move you know
it's very precautionary but it's a good
one
just moves the queen out of the eyeline
of the rook and
also maybe that queen on a fantastic day
might even start looking at the right
side
and that often happened in really wild
complicated battles he would
occasionally make these small blunders
that's why magnus is just trying to play
super solid chess right now
keep everything defended you did mention
it ivanka that black queen
may be going on an adventure trying to
lead from the front that black queen
stepped forward
attacking one of white central pawns
forcing the white rook to shift across
toward passive square
i don't like that move by magnus too
much that white rook maybe it was
necessary
but that white rook not a happy piece
later on in your future games you're
going to think
okay he does go active however he does
push a pawn in the center
cleanses of this move unless there's
something concrete
all black has done is actually lengthen
the diagonal of the dark squared bishop
um and i i can uh
okay well we are actually seeing some
direct action from
ding but in great defensive formation
okay ding decides
he can go for it he's gone with a night
sacrifice offering up that night if it's
captured now
okay magnus ignoring that night if it
was captured then the black bishop would
have
come to come to life it would have taken
the pawn pinning the white rook and
coming towards the white king
magnus ignoring the black knight which
is actually pinned push the white king
forward and
okay we see a check on the board and
after bishop takes knight
queen takes bishop knight takes bishop
and now the big threat unfortunately is
queen takes pawn check
and that is going to be game over
nothing to do about that so uh ding
losing material i mean is there any hope
i have to i have to mention as well i
mean for dingli ren
this is the first time he reached the
knockout phase because we know he's been
playing in the middle of the night in
china in the other tournaments and he is
before this tournament in 19th place on
the tour standings
so he's fighting desperately to get
those chore points to qualify for the
big finals well and i bet
um a third place and a fourth place here
he gives up the
first game